angela arena is with us now morning
didn't we very happy in the comments
yesterday
no it's astonishing that the prime
minister thinks he could just say i'm
sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry and get away
with breaking his own laws it's
it's astounding i never thought we'd be
in a position like this and you know
it's incredible that he heard that
testimony from kierstarma when he talked
about the constituent who had lost their
loved one and wasn't able to be there i
just said well i'm sorry and i've said
that and that's enough you know it's not
enough he's broke his own laws and he
knows that he should resign you've seen
pictures of your own boss though
breaking laws in durham we've seen the
photograph of him you know inside having
a sandwich and a beer well let's be
clear kirsten didn't break colvid rules
he hasn't been investigated by the
police in his hand though inside he did
not break any of the colvid rules he has
not been investigated by the police and
this is complete distraction when the
prime minister knows full well he was
partying many times in downing street
when he was telling the nation every
single day that they had to do their bit
for the public so this is pure
distraction that he knows that that's
not the case with kirsten and he knows
what he's done he's wrong that's why he
doesn't want the vote to go through
tomorrow because if that vote goes
through tomorrow then he knows that
committee which is majority conservative
made up if that committee finds that he
did mislead parliament knowingly that he
has to resign led by a labour politician
though and uh jacob reese
the definition of that of that committee
is made up of of conservatives as well
which is a conservative majority
what jacob smog said which was basically
he was suggesting it wouldn't be
impartial because chris bryant is in
charge of the committee well that's just
rubbish and he knows that's just rubbish
you know that committee has been set up
for a very long time as i say there's a
majority of conservatives he's saying
that his conservative colleagues would
be led by chris brown and not make their
own judgment i'm sure he's not saying
that because he knows full well that
that committee is set up to look at
things impartially and to look at the
evidence and if boris johnson has
mislead parliament which is pretty clear
that he has then he knows that that's
breaking the ministerial code and he has
to resign
there's already a sue grey report that
we will see in the fullness of time
goodness knows how much the police
inquiry is costing us why do we need
another investigation well again months
and months of the prime minister just
trying to say nothing to see here let's
move on are we all bored of partygate
well if you look back where the country
was at the time the prime minister has
lied to the country it's not just about
him breaking his rules is he broke his
rules and then tried to get away with it
and lie to parliament and lie to the
british public you know we accepted
other people's resignation for even less
than what the prime minister has been
found guilty of with his fixed penalty
notes he lied to parliament though can
you because you don't know what was in
his head so you don't know whether he
knew or not well why is he um avoiding
the scrutiny of that committee with the
evidence that they will have the
evidence
they will they will be able to have the
evidence and that committee will be very
clear on whether or not he did miss lee
parliament it's pretty clear he did miss
lee parliament it's pretty astounding
that he thinks he can say there was no
parties but he's found out these parties
this outrageous we didn't know there was
parties going on then when he was found
out to have been at the party is he
saying i didn't know it was a power what
is it i mean it's ridiculous
it's it's not a bit of cake in the
tupperware box you know we've been told
that swings were broken there was that
much he wasn't there
oh well we don't know because we haven't
got the full sue
yeah no we do we know that he was
actually to be fair he was up at
checkers when that happened oh well we
know that he's had numerous parties at
downing street and that he's tried to
and he's tried to get away with because
they've been well documented that the
prime minister he's trying to get away
with not coming to parliament and
telling the truth and that's the point
and the ministerial code is very clear
that if the prime minister or any
minister comes to parliament and lies to
parliament that misleads parliament that
it's a resignation effect
because there are five other events that
the prime minister was allegedly at the
police you know we trust our police
service here in the uk they will get to
the bottom of that they've already said
he broke the rules once um and we've
also got the sue grey report why a why
do we need another report and b why
can't we just wait until we see that
conclusion comes because we've had
months and months of the prime minister
trying what's wrong with waiting a bit
longer because we need a prime minister
that people have trust and confidence in
it's a red line if the prime minister of
this country believes that they can
break the ministerial code lie to the
british public and get away with it then
quite frankly all bets are off for our
rules and our democratic process so it's
a problem for all of us
including decades of going forward where
ministers from now on will think we
don't need to apply the ministerial code
because quite frankly the rules don't
apply to us we can break the law and it
doesn't matter anybody's people are not
stupid and there is a there is a local
elections for the for most of the
country coming up very soon so why not
wait until the fifth of may and see what
the british people think well the
british people obviously in those local
elections will have a vote on those
local issues but the point is well i
think we know it'll be on
boris johnson well i don't i don't know
what people are going to go to the
ballot box and choose what what
generally it's why they voted why they
why they want to vote in those local
elections but what i am clear on is the
prime minister has broke the law broke
the ministerial code and he should have
resigned months ago and he's trying to
deflect and get away with not being
answerable to those committees and those
rules that are put in place to protect
our democracy and protect the british
people and this prime minister thinks
the rules don't apply to him that is
reckless and dangerous i've raised this
again when he disregarded the
information from the parliamentary
committee on appointments to the lords
from the secret service that gave him
advice and he just disregarded it this
is a pattern of behaviour from a prime
minister who thinks the rules don't
apply to him
yeah but the poli the politicians are
not above the law as we as we know the
police are investigating why do we need
politicians to investigate if the police
are already doing it because they know
they're better than you guys sure and
the prime minister has already been
found that he broke the law he should
have resigned months ago we didn't need
the police investigation the prime
minister knew where he was he knew that
the party is ridiculous for him to say i
didn't know was at a party he set those
laws he knew what the rules were he's
trying to get away with it which is a
pattern of behaviour from boris johnson
he made a mistake and he got a fixed
penalty notice he didn't make a mistake
he parted when people weren't able to
see their loved ones when they were
dying he told the british people daily
that it was their duty to protect other
people by staying at home and doing the
right thing and not socializing he knew
that that was not okay to do that he's
trying to get away with it now rules
matter the law matters in this country
and the prime minister cannot get away
with this this issue is not going to go
away
because you don't have enough votes in
the house of commerce well we will
continue to push because there are
important issues we've been raising
issues around the cost of living we've
been supporting the government on
ukraine nobody is indispensable and
nobody is above the law in this country
and this prime minister needs to
recognize that his mps need to reinforce
that because if they don't they
undermine our democracy it's not just
about boris johnson it's about going
forward anyone including if kirsten
becomes prime minister if they think
that they can do it without um you know
being truthful to the british public if
they think they can do it with breaking
their laws that they set then that's
dangerous for our country but really i
mean just are you suggesting that it
would just be a free-for-all if if boris
johnson got away with allegedly um um
speaking to parliament in an appropriate
fashion that you would all do it
well i'm not saying all of us will
because that's the whole point the point
is is that those rules are there because
we have integrity parliamentarians have
integrity and honestly we have the nolan
principles that uh underpin that which
john major set up many years ago
conservative prime minister and he's
spoken out about this because it matters
it matters to our democracy it matters
to people like me who do uphold the law
who do believe in the parliamentary
process that he cannot continue with a
prime minister that breaks the law who
thinks that he can lie to parliament and
get away with it it's a red line we've
got to install that that cannot be the
case i'm glad you didn't give me that
face that you were giving the prime
minister yesterday in the comments
because that would have been a bit scary
it and i thought my paddington from the
staff face was good it's a novel
me and rachel me and rachel was just we
were both so upset you know and it's a
northern thing it's our it's our resting
face yeah i've got one of those as well
i'm glad you didn't use the other word
because it is breakfast jelly it's good
to see you thank you much appreciated